[Applaudissements]
salut
Eric tu vas bien ça va et toi ouais
regarde ce que j'ai trouvé
donc c'est une Barbie numéro 3 et par
contre j'ai trouvé le petit costume mais
je voudrais savoir si il y a tous les
tous les accessoires là
de pique-nique
je trouvais ça une vente aux enchères
tu dois avoir le petit chapeau avec la
grenouille
là c'est bon la petite mallette en
osier oui c'est ça donc le chemisier le
pantalon les chaussures d'un non
compensé ils sont différents des
chaussures
[Musique]
c'est très commercial mais aucun rapport
avec Barbie donc stop
la première poupée c'est une Barbie Rio
donc qui pourrait ne pas être une Barbie
pour les gens qui connaissent pas trop
vu qu'elle est brune et qu'elle ait la
peau très mal alors que Baby Barbie
pardon à la a les cheveux blonds et à la
peau blanche c'est Barbie Rio la plus
ancienne que je possède c'est celle-ci
c'est une pony tail
queue de cheval tout à fait très bien
qui porte un costume qui se prénomme
solom the spotlight
vu que voilà l'Europe de scène qui était
vendue avec un micro que j'ai dans ma
petite vitrine donc c'est une poupée qui
date de 1960 au niveau collectionneur on
appelle ça le numéro 4
voilà c'est un costume des années 60
donc les chaussures la robe les gants le
petit chapeau qui est sur une poupée des
années 70 j'ai trouvé que ça lui allait
très bien
donc voilà voilà les choses que
j'apprécie le plus
j'ai participé à un concours l'autre des
lors des conventions qu'on a avec notre
club et qui a un club de collectionneur
pouvait même en France il fallait créer
un costume haute couture donc voilà je
m'amuse je poinçonne des petites
pastilles en aluminium pour faire une
une réplique d'un costume de Paco
Rabanne pas une réplique puisque j'ai
pas eu de modèle j'ai décidé de faire ça
donc voilà mais mes créations c'est plus
du bricolage que de la couture
c'est rigolo c'est rigolo c'est rigolo
une femme une femme qui ressemble à
Barbie ça doit être une femme ennuyeuse
il doit falloir énormément de temps pour
se coiffer pour se maquiller énormément
de temps dans les magasins et énormément
d'argent pour s'acheter tout ça donc non
je rêve pas du tout d'une femme qui
ressemble à Barbie loin de là j'aime
Barbie parce que c'est un jouet parce
que c'est une poupée plus un jouet
qu'une poupée d'ailleurs mais non je
n'aimerais pas la femme qui ressemblera
Barbie je vous invite à un dessin
de ce tango presque argentin où je ferai
la connaissance de votre corps contre le
mien
vous vous ferez la découverte de cet
exotic entretien lorsque la musique est
offerte il faut la suivre sachez le bien
entrer dans mon Tangoo et je vous
danserai les yeux à demi clos perdus au
milieu des collectionne une passion pour
les les réseaux de ferroviaires donc les
petits trains et mon petit frère adore
et collectionne tout ce qui concerne la
guerre des étoiles donc ça va des petits
des poupées aussi des petits personnages
des petites figurines au vaisseau
spatial au maquettes ou là c'est encore
c'est encore un autre domaine mais c'est
un virus familial quand oui quand un
garçon collectionne des poupées ça peut
choquer a priori ça doit choquer
certains mais bon
c'est une passion que que
j'affectionne comme toute passion toute
façon qu'il faut assouvir mais je suis
pas je suis pas Fada au point de de
craquer des sommes d'argent phénoménales
pour pouvoir acquérir quelque chose qui
a été sorti à un demi exemplaire
oui c'est pas forcément la rareté non
j'achète ce que j'aime ce qui me plaît
donc on pourrait même proposer une
poupée qui a été faite à un seul
exemplaire qui serait en or massif avec
des diamants partout pour donner un
ordre de rareté quoi bon si elle est pas
belle elle est pas belle si elle me
plaît pas elle me plaira pas
j'avais envie d'une poupée Barbie et vos
parents n'ont jamais voulu vous en
acheter une
hors de question et même à l'heure
actuelle pourtant étant établi un homme
normal travaille en normalement ayant
une viande peut plus normale maman ne
veut toujours pas m'acheter de poupée
même pour Noël au bon anniversaire
mais quand elle voit votre collection
elle est quand même épatée non et à
l'heure actuelle ouais épater et enfin
les patients peut dire elle apprécie
quand même
interloqué souvent et son rêve par
contre elle se serait de porter des
robes que les poupées ont à l'heure
actuelle
en faisant de l'humour je crois que
Barbie pourrait passer dans X-Files
parce que c'est s'adapter à tout donc
elle est un peu caméléon
[Musique]